all right baby boys and baby bats i'm
that baby bat boy
you know what i'm saying i'll [ __ ] in
your yard son you feel me gang
we out here we staying alive baby that's
all there is to it
we stand alive on the lord's blood drive
son
you know i'm that f i'm that freaking
jam pirate dog
i'll suck that jelly boy right out your
freaking nephew's
neck you know this
you know what i'm saying i'll get that
she's
herbs boy i'll suck that that preserves
right out your grandmother's freaking
spinal column boy you know l5s
yum baby you feel me i'm getting it and
let's start this podcast today baby i
got that raspy voice
and a lot of y'all already wet from it
baby a lot of y'all already greased up
down in that bottom knuckle baby you
know what i'm saying
that weiner and a lot of y'all fellas
probably already sadly i mean not sadly
it's okay and it's good if you are
but some of y'all already probably
dripping off that bag from daddy
making y'all damn baby but
that's what it is
what it is what it ain't does the baby
need a spank let's go
you know it and i know it
[Music]
feels real good after i've been
it feels so good to have a brand new
[Music]
well i just moved up to lucky street
when the mayor
came and said to me
[Music]
and it's plain to see between you and me
i'm in ohio
[Music]
and what it ain't does the baby does the
baby
need a spank that's eddie 9 volt
right there 89 v with the come up
and i actually went to see them play the
other night
over there in um
out in the central east i went and saw
tried to see them
and i got there late because that's the
kind of guy i am
you know hell i'd be late to everything
man i
you know i climbed my own coughing late
there'll be people out there at my
funeral
and i climb i'll show up like oh sorry
guys
you know traffic
you know where i was just you know my
hair was wet
and then i'll get in there i i'll climb
it and cough and everybody okay go on
about your thing
you know
uh having me a liquid death i gotta keep
that pole
moist baby i gotta keep that um i gotta
keep my spout
uh lavished up because my
throat i was out in
phoenix out there the rally in the
valley people are fired up out there
about their hoops team
and they're playing hoops out there they
got a lot of brothers out in the desert
and i think one white
and they hooping the hell out of the
damn ball out there and uh
and that's it and so everybody's fired
up out there and
and i was out there i was out there and
uh
man it was dude it was definitely
uh it was it was it was a good time good
time out there i stayed at a
like this kind of sober living place
while i was there and it was
they had a gu i like one night they had
somebody got in a motorcycle
accident and they came to the door like
the police came
and uh and i felt kind of bad because
the day before we were all going to the
gym
if you've never been to a sober living
sometimes when you're there everybody
you get in a van and you all go
somewhere together
because you just that's who you are
you know it's like uh it's like a
daycare but for adults
that
are
that would sometimes rather probably
have drugs than lunch
so if you're like lunchtime and somebody
shot up
it's like that sort of camaraderie that
sort of club
style style and so um
so anyway we got there i got there and
uh because i went to this therapy thing
for a week to this like kind of
intensive therapy place because you know
me bro
i got uh i either have something i
either got you know i'm always
put pressing the gas on that something's
wrong with me pedal you know
so i'm in that freaking hov lane bro
something's wrong with everybody you
know what i'm saying i'm bringing it's
all aboard so anyway i met this sober
living dude they got um
oh god they had it's like you know it's
regular people
if you ever been to one it's a real
hodgepodge of america
it's kind of like a lost and found
but a couple more lost
it's lost heavy and so i'm there you
know i roll up
and uh they got a there's one guy 65-ish
you know
and whenever you ask him anything hey
man what's going on he's like just being
just
this is just staying sober this thing is
over
what you're doing is going to be over
this he would put his hands up like it
was like the police were
like every time you were like hey man is
there any milk out of just
being sober you know not from around
here like
everything was like i remember like one
time i
just asked him a question you know i was
like hey what's the weather like and he
handed me his license and registration
so you know there's some real you know
america's top miscreants you know it's a
real it's
it's regular folks man you know and
i could have stayed in a hotel or motel
or
um hell i could have been homeless if i
wanted to but i chose to be
here there where i was
so yeah it was wild they had us uh uh
acidic jewish dude i don't know if you
ever even
seen this this guy
had on like
all these coats he had like uh
he looked like he looked like
like biggie smalls
but like biggie smallsburg kind of
like he had on like he had on like a a
jacket
it was so thick it was a hundred and
probably 11 degrees out there
you know you could feel a [ __ ] i mean
it feel i felt like there was a dragon
outside
that's the levels of
air heat
because the air will hold heat the air
is just really just a briefcase for damn
heat or cold
you know that's mother nature's
briefcase man
the air because that's where she puts
all of her [ __ ]
you know but anyway so this fella man he
was as
i mean he was you know this little
gamble spinner was about as damn jewish
as you could get he had on
he he had on the hat the hat had on a
hat
he had like he yeah he uh
and if you haven't seen hasidic jewish
person you got to look it up
because i'd never seen it i'd seen it
maybe you know in the distance
i'd seen like one of these hj's at a
distance but i'd never seen up close
you know and this fella he had on the
head he had on the dr
the drapes the curtains he had on the
door
he had on nine it was he had on 19
layers of clothing he had socks his
socks were wearing brassieres like
he had i can't even imagine
he was wearing about four loads of
laundry
and he shows up and he's like hi and it
was uh it was 119 degrees
and if you don't know anything about
hasidic culture
they can't drive on
uh the sabbath on like from friday
sundown i think until saturday sundown
so these fellas these bad boys and girls
they got a walk
so this dude had basically
i mean he'd probably come from mars
you could hear his like
his shoe or it was just whatever it was
just like
he's like hi it's hot
like yeah it's hot man and so ever you
know people's air body you know it's a
damn sober living some do you know
one guy in the kitchen i'm like oh man
we're having dinner like this salad is
so good and he's like yeah
it's really good i was dead for 30
minutes two weeks
ago so everything's good all right damn
okay bro
okay man down so you really
you really tasting this ranch you're
really tasting
this fat free ranch today and you you
know
you're really enjoying and appreciating
and gratitude in that uh
that ranch um
but this is so uh
what uh it was cool they had like a
little um
place to swim in the back and it was so
hot the water you got in the water it
was like being in uh um
it was like hiding in somebody's mouth
say you had
say you were playing hide-and-go-seek
with people
and you somebody was uh had a heat
stroke
a real big person big big so
probably 11 feet tall maybe 600 pounds
and you hid in their mouth
during uh hide and go seek and you hid
in their mouth
that would be what the heat was like
that hot you know
somebody who had a heat stroke and was
also
um they were late
there was also somebody was pouring heat
on them
somebody had two bags of damn heat and
was just filling them [ __ ] up with it
warming them
um so that was wild
uh and then so the crazy thing is so
we're all going to the gym one day and
this one fella had gotten a new
motorbike
and he's kind of coasting through the
red lights and just living life you know
and uh and you know and i respect no
helmets because
the lord is looking for some people
and everybody wants to be alive and
everything and
and i get it but we don't
know
what it's like when you die
i mean it must here's the thing it's so
good i bet
it's so good nobody's coming back from
it
there was a couple ghosts i think that
came back allegedly from the
1700s or whatever but them [ __ ]
apparently they fixed heaven up because
nobody's been coming back name the last
ghost you even heard about
you know ray charles maybe or somebody i
don't even know who
i mean he's not a ghost i mean he's
blind but that's that's not a ghost a
ghost is if you can't see them
so he's like a reverse ghost you know
but um but anyway
so we're out there we're crew we're
going to the gym in the
van you know if you do sober living just
you know you that dirty grade school
class you know you're just that
you know you're a little more lost than
fam
and so we rolling out and this other
fellow got a motorcycle
and so he's zipping in zoodad and doing
this and doing that and stunting letting
daddy
and i tell the other guys in the van i
said hey uh
it's i said i used to talk about organ
donation
because my sister make sure my head is
all right
my sister got an organ when i was a
child and she got a
liver she got liver and uh
which i wouldn't got i would have got
two hearts you know
you're like hey what are you doing i'm
like hey man throw another freaking
throw another pump in here you know what
i'm saying but we all be running hot
dude all the dance moves you could do if
he was double-hearted
uh but but so anyway the um
the uh so so anyway this guy's skirting
and stuff and go we're all headed to the
gym
this guy's skirting around on this on
his bike
and uh and i say man guys you know i
said he's he's really
reckless you know he's a reckless man
out here
and i said a lot of organ donors
the next day i come home and uh
the the fella the police had shown up
and the fella had been in a accident
in a coma or comma
you know they're both pauses
and and we're like
why i'm like am i predicting the future
right now
so it was just you know and i hope he's
in
i i you know i need to check and see if
he's i'm gonna text somebody right now
see if the guy still comb it up
yeah i'm gonna see if he's okay uh so
so anyway i don't they had a candlelight
vigil like on the third night
the full uh the fifth night uh it was
cool we got to sit in there and watch
like some basketball games together
and hockey uh the canadians
you know those frogs bro i don't know if
anybody
follows hockey but it'd be awesome to
cheer for the canadians if
everybody else in canada didn't hate him
that's the weird thing
montreal is like kind of that french bad
boy
you know it's like everybody else is in
a big fight and then you got some dude
over there smoking a cigarette and
sucking on the freaking
on the on the dirty side of a crepe you
know what i'm saying that back hole baby
that back jaw
you know somebody freaking uh
you know sneaking into a crepe all nasty
from the back dude
eat a crepe from the front you creep
and crepe and creep is just one letter
different bro
so if you want nasty eggs dog get them
french you feel me
get them french
praise god man and then the last day i'm
there the uh
hasidic guy shows up hello
this dude had i mean i don't think he'd
ever seen reg non uh
sids you know non um hasidic
people because it's a real tight cult
it's basically like
they're like the uh
they're kind of like the financial
native americans kind of you know
they're real
or i don't they're like man they're real
religious
like way religious
like i was telling my friend josh wolfe
about it and he said that hasidic people
don't even consider him jewish they're
like
you gotta be in there
but that guy they gave him a chapstick
somebody and he never used
it so for the next like 14 hours this
dude is over there just going hard bro
just going hard on some pink lemonade
baby
he had that pink lemonade chaps taking
everything about every nine seconds
you'd look over and he'd be like
[Music]
dude that dude i think he by the time i
left and he had chapstick his whole
face he had chapstick his he
just couldn't stop man you know and
thankfully we're all you know everybody
that's in the places
had some issues with addiction so at
least he's in the right place now
but and also at least if the sun hits
him now out there he'll have a little
bit of uh
of a block on him you know
because that's
hello dude it was anyway
it was needless to say it was a wild
week
uh but what else we had
uh mario gutierrez if you get to check
out that jockey episode
man it was real fascinating to hear
about a jockey
and just to see the on the horse you
know that it's on the horse you know
like
you ever get the sushi they put the rice
down first
you know they put that little baby bed
of rice bruh
and then they hit that [ __ ] that little
dose of fish man
you feel me they really just laced that
thing up with that little freaking
it's just like a little baby sleeping
bag of pescado on their fish
get you a little tuna on there or
something a little salmon
you know some people go eel perverts
but i don't i don't
but that's kind of how it is with that
jockey that that the horse is that rice
and then it
set that thing right on there
you know so it was just real interesting
here what it's like to be that little
baby bird
and be going for the prize and getting
the money
for the rich people and it's really just
rich people saying hey won't you ride on
this for me that's
i mean let's it's rich people paying
small people to ride on an animal
which is very roman sounding
i think but what do i know
my nephews are in town uh i'm gonna try
to have them
on this podcast at the end of the
episode
what will that be like i don't know
but i think it even if it's just for a
few minutes i think it'll be
entertaining to them
and uh yeah that could be fun man
uh got an announcement to make gonna
tape a netflix special coming up
and that's going to be uh in nashville
tennessee
we will tape it in the central east
um it just the way it worked out
i was looking to go to dallas but i'm
also
very excited to be in nashville for it
so that's going to be a real excitement
time and uh
and i just feel lucky i feel lucky to
that i have the opportunity
you know to get out there and um
and we'll light up the dark arts that's
what it's going to be
you know so if you've already seen the
dark arch you might not want to see it
if you want to see the dark arts in a
theater
and you haven't seen that we'll be
taping that over at the ryman and we're
going to do a couple of shows and uh
and i'm excited about it man i'm really
excited about it come on hello
i'm upstairs um
upstairs
still thinking of tour names return of
the rat
has been ringing around in my head
return of the rat what else can i talk
what else can i tell you that happened
um
oh got an update that fella is still
oh he's still in a coma oh and he has
brain damage actually but
so man
my heart goes out to him and
it just you know he
this guy was a word the second you saw
this guy he was a warrior
you know he's just one of those people
that just
some people just are so fearless
you know this fellow was just tatted up
just freaking he was a real
warrior and there's something to be said
for going out hard
and i'm gonna keep him in uh in my
prayers man and
uh and hopefully he bounces back but
just a crazy
timing just what a week at that place
you know
what a week at that place and and it
just reminded me how much i
i i don't spend that much time around
people
and so it was nice just to be around
you know to sit and watch the game split
a little orange bruh
oh you want some orange oh you want some
orange
oh this dude's nodding off bro he's been
on them heroin hitters dog wake him up
and [ __ ] hit him with that vitamin c
baby slice dog
that anaranjado and i think that means
orange
in spanish what else is going on i've
been trying not to masturbate man
and uh
and i haven't been having any luck with
it or i have been having luck with it or
but i haven't i've been masturbating
that's what i'm saying so
i'm not bad or anything i'm not a bad
guy i just
been masturbating man
sometimes i get squirreled out
you know sometimes i just get so like at
night sometimes i get so squirreled out
and i feel like the devil just put damn
70 squirrels in my [ __ ] arms
and i just i get like that and i just
have to damn
i just have to make something come you
know
and i hate to say it like that but i
just have to damn
you know i hate to use that language but
i just i got to make something
you know i just feel like i got to make
something spray
and i'm glad i'm you know at that point
i'm glad i'm doing it to myself and not
you know on you know on taking somebody
else's body or
you know doing anything wild you know so
so yeah sometimes you just gotta you
know all you got is that
that that little baby griddle you know
and you got to grill your own cake
and that's what i've been doing
sometimes so i would like to back off of
that especially in the summer man you
don't want to be jerking yourself down
and then the heat's hitting you're like
oh [ __ ]
i feel like a raisin and i don't have
any coom in my body bro i don't have any
of that
freaking nut that newt
so i'll tell you this though it's a not
so
fun fact americans overspend on
insurance by
21 billion dollars every year
not shocked i don't know if you've met
some of these americans
but they are a trying group
that's where the zebra can help you the
zebra
compares car and home insurance quotes
from every major provider in under five
minutes giving you all the facts you
need
to make the right decision all for free
it's the fastest way to find the right
coverage
at the right price all from a provider
that you can trust in fact the zebra
it's that stripedy trustworthy friend
the zebra shoppers save an average of
on home and car insurance combined it's
a lot of money
it's almost a thousand dollars a year if
you can find some way to save
78 more dollars so
can you start comparing quotes for free
today by visiting
the zebra.com theo that's
the zebra dot com
slash theo save your money use it for
something you enjoy
ah here's something else you should know
that the
price of gold if you remember gold from
the 15 and 1600s
has been all over the place lately
now there's a new way to buy gold
through a company called
acre it lets you subscribe to gold bars
for as little as 30 a month
you pay each month and once your gold
stash reaches
the price of their gold bars they
discreetly
ship you acre gold to your house
that's right fresh acre gold
and just recently acre has introduced a
new hundred dollar a month subscription
to a five gram gold bar
that's right acre lets you invest in
physical gold without coming out of
pocket all at once
so it's that that gradual plan is that
staircase baby
it's that staircase baby and that's what
i am
i'm a staircase baby visit
get acre gold g-e-t a-c-r-e-g-o-l-d
dot com theo and start investing in
physical gold today
when the world ends when the money is
all gone
which could happen the way we're headed
i met a homeless guy the other day he
gave me 40 dollars
make sure you go to this url because
acre is giving away a gold bar
that's right to qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient
and mention at acre underscore gold
again that's get acre gold dot com slash
theo where you can figure it all out
thank you acre gold
for supporting the show
[Music]
you know i've been having a tough time
with um the sonic commercial
is that the only place that we are
eating now
is that it every commercial i see is
just sonic
it's like hey is that the best we can do
as a family that was to
sit together in a car somewhere
there's some kid he's like he's 11
genders he's got that coin thing on his
belt or her belt or on his neck
he's on suicide watch he's on a uh
a ransom list he's an orphan he's a
he's a burn victor you have it's always
somebody that works there they have
every impediment you could have
you know the guy been hit by a car he's
been hit by a truck
you know it's like uh it's definitely
somebody that god is looking for
okay that's who is the employee
and they used to roller skate out to you
you know kind of cute
a little scary when the girl coming out
of roller skates is pregnant that's the
spooky one you're like okay
we just wanted a couple blizzards we
don't want no zygote but
i hope henrietta don't trip on one of
these cracks in the pavement
you know we'll just you know god forbid
you know she'd lose her child because we
wanted a damn mcflazzle
and then the family of families sitting
in their dads in the front
i just wonder what is this like for kids
now
at least when i was a kid we went to the
pizza hut
we went in there my dad got a beer or
pulled one out of his
pocket that he brought in there and
asked for a cold glass
my mom sat
kinda near my dad i don't think she
cared about him but i do
think she wanted pizza
i really do and we would sit in there
they would give us some quarters my dad
always had quarters
you know it was all he was older they
had quarters they used to have quarters
and he would get a couple out give them
to us we'd go play the video games
we lose sometimes we [ __ ] up we put yeah
it takes three quarters you put in one
you're [ __ ] you're the k you know you
didn't read the direction you're just
hitting the button nothing happens
you tell the guy there he doesn't know
he makes pizza you tell the delivery
guy's going on you're like the quarter
he's like uh i'm
you know i'm high i just got robbed
you're like well
we're getting robbed everybody's
getting robbed
and then we played a game then when we'd
have anymore we would look under the
machines we would
my one of us would we would use all of
our little baby strength to lift the
machine up somebody would reach under
there
pull out half a hamster full of hats to
pull out half a hamster of hair
four barrettes
you know and and maybe uh maybe a
quarter
maybe a quarter comes out with it
then we get the pizza the deep dish
pizza hut used to have the best pizza
pizza hut is a crust of its former self
now they're shooting the [ __ ] crust
uh a crust up with cheese it's like uh
you know it's like that bob baffert
scandal you know you don't know what
they're injecting into this [ __ ] to get
you to believe in it
i remember when the crust stood on its
own
you know when is a real italian gonna
make a pizza place
that has some freaking zagoon huh
when you're gonna put some real gonads
on the [ __ ] pie
so we can enjoy it again this [ __ ] out
here domino it's just a flavor it's not
even a thing it's not even
it's barely pizza
and sonic you're sitting dad's in the
front it's like the best we can do as a
family is dry
sit in the car you got the kid in the
back he has probably
asthma and autism and asthmatism he
[ __ ] can't breathe or know what's
going on if there's loud noises
it just you know dad's up there spilling
chili on himself
mom's over there huffing birth control
you know it just i just don't know
it used to be at least on the
commercials they were around a
dinner table
now it's like hey drive over here
you know park here by the freaking busy
road
oh smell the exhaust while little
lawrence in the back seat
chokes on his damn grilled cheese
i don't know maybe i'm salty about i
don't know why i'm salty but i like it
i like it it takes forever though at
least there used to be a roller skating
girl
you know you see a couple young tits
come out on some wheels
you know make you touch your [ __ ]
crotch for a second
but now you know who knows what it is
now it's just damn you know
it's some kid he comes to the way he
tells you he's an orphan
he's like you know i'm an orphan i'm
like do you have the burgers
okay we're not here
for anything but the burgers
do you have the burgers
[Music]
hey do you have
the burgers
he's like i used to be in a wheelchair
you're like do you have a
guy
i can't live downstairs anymore baby
because you know where i am
amen baby praise god rat king
oh what else
what else happened um i got some plants
i got some dang marigolds
i got some azaleas
i put in i installed them bastards
went over there to home depot and
and the crazy thing about home depot
they give you that cart in the plant
section
it has like 12 wheels but it also only
somehow has
two wheels you know it like does
it doesn't go any direction really
it looks like kind of a piece of a
merry-go-round that got taken
you're like i know where i'll just take
this right over
you freaking kill some contractor you're
just trying to buy a damn
gratioli
what else man let's go to a call we got
a lot of cool stuff
here's something that happened in the
news everything had a sign
and down goes tony martin oh tony martin
you hate to see this you know and
i i don't know what i think of this yet
i don't have to take a day to process
what i think of the spectators on the
side of the road but
yeah unfortunately tony martin and that
is the uh
tour de france you know
which is basically steroiding and biking
i've met other friends in it they're all
this whole thing is just a damn dope
show i mean it's basically marilyn
manson
but everybody's real athletic it's
everybody's out here
it's all just i mean they're drinking
each other's blood at night they're
doing it all
you know these people's on anti-freeze
over freeze death
dead decadent they're shooting 200 damn
things a decadent right into their damn
armpit
testosterone uh
everything these guys are fired up
they're french and they're fired up
and somebody got in the way with a sign
i'm not going to say who it was it was a
woman
and i'm not going to say who was we
don't allegedly i don't know if they
know who it was yet
but some lady some meme
making [ __ ] whistle
okay and yeah i'm fired up today got in
the way
with a sign so they could get a cute
video
while the french
okay no matter what you think about them
um are doing this [ __ ]
and i think they should have let the
guys
i think you almost got to let them go
back and run over the ladies legs with
the bite
that's
it seems fair got some shows added
st louis we have it might be sold out
if it is we might add another one
cincinnati
you can get tickets charlotte you can
get tickets still
and durham chattanooga
show added there knoxville wilmington
wilkes-barre
minneapolis richmond baltimore portland
maine
burlington vermont uh
albany show added buffalo
at klein hines music hall in columbus
we've added a show over there
and uh i'm gonna say thank you
man you know i think i was really scared
over the pandemic
you know i said when i get back out
there will people come and see it
you know and so i'm excited to know that
uh
that you guys are coming in and i'm
gonna bring some heat man
i'm gonna bring a little bit of heat so
get your chapstick on your face okay
because daddy's about to blaze them
eyebrows off you know what i'm saying
gang gang boy
i'll eat one of my damn nuts bruh
you know what i'm saying and say i
didn't fam gang [ __ ]
all right but that was a tour de france
and that's what's going on
that's what happens when you're [ __ ]
around out there
so you know uh
and everybody it's just you it's just
we've come to that place where it's more
about the
picture of the thing than even the event
is going on it's more about the meme
it's more about the moment
it's interesting because it's the
minutiae it's more
but also would anyone even know about
the tour de france if this lady wasn't
standing there with a sign
would anybody even know
that these freaking roid monsters who
were blowing their nuts out
remember lance armstrong blew one of his
damn nuts out
shooting up
i mean that you know if he's staying if
he stands on his head that's like a
it's like a seal with a ball on his nose
you know
that dude's one riding bro and he
he and at least we knew because he won
so many
but if the sign [ __ ] doesn't maybe it
could all be a ploy
[Music]
it could all be a ploy to get us to
watch
so here's a couple of video questions
that came in i want to thank you guys
for sending them
in what's up guys
leo quick question my roommate's dating
a roller derby chick she's 6'3
has a pretty crazy mullet it's nothing
like yours
but um she every time she comes home
uh with my roommate she wants to fight
me tickle me
she's always saying really rude things
to me what do you think i should do
about this because i can't hit her
i could easily beat the [ __ ] out of her
but she's pretty big she wants that
guy should i treat her like a dude or
should i just treat her like some weirdo
at the gas station
you know i was at the gas station the
other night man and it's
[ __ ] is lit out there
there's a fella there i swear was bobby
lee okay
and bobby will deny it because he's
sleeping you know
no wonder you live forever if you're
asian if you sleep
21 hours a day
then you're probably gonna live a long
time
so i think a big gal like that take her
back man
i think once a woman gets up over six
two they ought to say it's a man
and i'll say that again i think once a
woman gets up over six
two there should be
you know i don't know how tall you are
brother that sent this in blake
you know and thank you for the question
brother gang praise god
don't let the lord miss you man
you know i told someone i say you know
one time i said man i'm really looking
for the lord and they said the lord
ain't lost
and that hit me that hit me right in the
dick man
sorry man i'm really and i'm not sorry
you know i got to let some of this
stress on buddy i have had so much
stress
in my neck and top of my right part of
my back for a year and a half
it will not go away i do not know what
is going on
i'm 20 days off caffeine right now
thinking maybe that could help
so but i'm not complaining here's what
i'm saying bro i think at a certain
point of five three guys should be able
to fight a 6-2 woman
and you're thinking about it too right
now and you're not really disagreeing
so i think yeah
i think you definitely should not
you know i think you can take her back
though i think you can like
wrestle her you know when the times are
changing man it's trans now it's like
they got
woman's fighting men they got sheep
fighting people
lamar odom beat the last bit of
sexuality out of damn
uh aaron
uh chalmer
so what the hell you know that's where
we are
would it be shocking i think as long as
you put it online and let people bet on
it you got you could [ __ ] attack her
at the house if you want
but i don't know that
you know i would ask your friend and see
what he thinks man i think you have a
middle person there
but i would definitely wrestle with her
you know or tickle that [ __ ] real hard
dawg
you know so praise god brother thank you
brother
thank you for being a part of my life
um i'll have my nephews in here in a few
minutes let me get into a little more
here's a video question that came in
these are all video ones
what's up mr vaughn charles here from
pemberton bc
what's up pepperdine bc man um
not sure that is before christ
[Music]
so i don't even know i you know and i
believe in god i i don't know
i don't know where this maybe this is a
pepperdine breezy man i'm gonna have to
look it up
maybe go to a service there or something
man um
thank you brother onward got a quick
question for you you ever tried a
snowmobile up before
they're a big thing out here just
wondering if you ever give it a shot or
what you think of them
gang gang gang baby snowmobiling
and that's the lord if you can't walk on
water i guess at least you could
freaking ride on uh
frozen water and so i like what you guys
are doing out there and seeing what god
likes y'all being out
in the cold you know god will let you
out in the cold but
at a certain point he shuts it down and
you die
that's the risky part about it baby is
that second part
so let's see what we got right here
here's a question that came in from a
uh pretty much a white guy
what up theo this is jackson larson
coming at you from
grand rapids michigan grand rapids maybe
good place to get some uh food at night
and um and wish you had a different wife
i noticed that a little bit when i was
there people kind of
you know hugging their wife but kind of
looking around so
thank you jackson onward just wondering
if you got any advice for a
couple of dudes uh renting a house
together i know you've been a uh
an adult tenant and
i just wondered if you got any advice
for uh
i don't know just living on your own for
the first time figuring that all out
yeah i think if you's a fella living on
your own you got to really have a good
time
and this one thing that goes back to
even just being at that sober living
place last week
i want to have a good time you're around
people utilize that
don't isolate you know in college i live
with a fella and
he was kind of an exotic dancer kind of
guy and he he tried to kill himself he
jumped out of a
out of the window one story building we
were on first floor dude
tried to jump out and didn't do [ __ ]
just got stuck outside but um
but yeah man i think you just got to
spend time together man
you know living on your own you're not
on your own
you're with somebody so you got somebody
in there
and set up times where you check on each
other make sure people aren't dead in
the house
you know hey buddy if it's 1 pm you
haven't heard from me come in there
you know take my damn pressure you know
what i'm saying make sure i'm good
so praise god brother stay alive um
see what else we got that came in
olympian who turned back on flag during
anthem says she feels
set up by u.s track and field oh i saw
this gwen berry turned away from the
flag while the anthem played
she later draped a t-shirt that said
activist athlete
um yeah
athletes can do whatever they want you
know i think
we definitely have been through a time
where
we got used to as a country for a long
time the athletes being happy to
represent the country they were in
represent america um
it's so funny there's a lot of people
who are like [ __ ] america but
america is just a society that's all it
is
and there's a lot of people out there
um who act like society like it's all
some big plan against them
it's just society you know
uh the activist athlete thing i think
some of it gets a little bit old
you know it's like look everybody people
have already done it
just play your sport
that's kind of how i feel a little bit i
also feel like she can do whatever she
wants
i feel like she'll just turn a lot of
people off
some companies or something will come
along and use her to
be a voice for them to get some product
pushed across
and that'll be that
you know now though it's a lot more
pressure if she doesn't even win
she got third place
third place yes it's great it's still
the olympics
but let's get first place
you didn't even beat two other countries
okay
you're like my country sucks like uh
it would have been better if you'd
gotten first your country would be
better
so i don't know i
i just i'm not i'm from the time where
man it would have been anything to be
able to perform for the u.s this isn't
my country it doesn't respect my views
it's just a group of people trying their
best that's all the country is
and she just wants to make it about her
that that's what i think it is
and that's just more the society it goes
back to the lady at the freaking
with the signage at the tour de france
she just wants to make it about her
you know it's just like how can i make
this about
me
and in some ways it's just kind of the
the generations that we're in right now
we want to have our own platform
oh this is who i am but this is also how
i feel
um i mean i do it here on on this
but there is an interesting thing
because we long have expected athletes
just to be an athlete like you're at
your job
but i do feel like it's kind of i feel
like it's disgraceful
to america that's what i feel like i
feel like yes you can do it
um but there's just a lot of people
there's no gratitude for where we
are you know
the national anthem upset her it was hot
out there i get it
some of those things look it's too hot
maybe they should have put them under a
thing she would have been more
comfortable
i was thinking about what i should do
barry added eventually i just stayed
there and just swayed i put my shirt
over my head it was real disrespectful
i knew they did that on purpose but
it'll be all right i'll see what's up
i see what's up yeah
look i've had this mentality people are
out to get me it's all about
me um i don't know
i think get first get first and then
we'll talk
that's kind of how i feel on it
but it makes me not want to cheer for
her i'm an american
you know i'm an american
and
you know and i want to say thanks to
everybody who's working right now
and actually trying to work there's so
many places there's nobody showing up to
work apparently
you know i get uh groceries and in the
bags there's these things it's like
we will interview you on the spot today
people don't want that job man
people don't want to work
so if you are working
that's awesome i commend you
you know i'm working too and i'm trying
my best and some people say well so what
some of us can't get jobs everybody can
get a job
you know i used to live with a felon he
would jerk off at night while his family
was asleep
you know and i know some of y'all know
about it and i would elbow crawl out to
the kitchen and
and uh and see what was in the fridge
try to do it without him knowing you
know he'd be at the computer and i'd
reach in the fridge real slow get my
hand in there and stop the light thing
and then open the door and try and get
what they had in there
they usually had olives and tostitos
they were wealthy but they didn't show
it in their food
they did other [ __ ] boating
that man said you always need to have a
job
you always need to have a job as a human
you need to be working
just as a soul as a thing you need to be
doing something
contributing to society it's just
society
people like [ __ ] america this guy go
somewhere else
go yeah and especially if you get third
place go somewhere else and get third
[ __ ] we number one here
biden orders air strikes against
facilities used by iran back militia
groups
i don't know a time about this type of
thing but
he probably thought he was ordering
lunch you know
he probably dude i just see him like
every couple of minutes just take a
pocket full of children's hair out of
his like a handful of children's hair
out of his pocket and just
just get that hit baby what
huh hello
who knows man that guy is so old bro
look and i'm telling you
i grew up with an old dad that starting
to fall apart
okay are we pretending he's not falling
apart
the dude can't get through a freaking
solid idea
he's mupping it around it's not a safe
place to be i don't feel like
i really don't feel like it's a safe
place to be
because it just feels like if the leader
could be controlled so much
by anyone who even tells him it's nap
time
anyone with a freaking bootleg golden
girls episode
i want to tell you right now that dinner
time can be
chaotic that's right but with freshly
it's easy their chefs take care of your
meals a few nights a week
and take the pressure off of you we're
all trying to get in shape and eat right
well freshly can help their delicious
meals are designed
by nutritionists and cooked by chefs
you know what chefs are dude
yeah they're making the food
solid people not some [ __ ] lame
the delicious meals are designed by
nutritionists and cooked by chefs making
it easier to eat better
are you stressed are you tired you just
don't feel like cooking
huh who can blame you don't drive to
dang sonic
and sit in the car dad spilled chili on
the steering wheel
freshly offers chef made nutrient-packed
delicious meals delivered fresh to your
door no cooking required
make it easy make it easy they can fit
your lifestyle
a variety of plans and meals to cook
from that work for your dietary needs
preferences tastes and family size
try freshly for six dollars and sixteen
cents per meal
stop searching the internet for healthy
food near me every night
start living freshly imagine just
opening your refrigerator
there it is and it was prepared it's not
manufactured
your meals are always delivered fresh
never frozen ready to eat and enjoy
just heat them up takes three minutes
with new meals added each week
freshly brings the convenience of chef
made nutritionist designed
classics uh right to your kitchen
and right now freshly is offering our
listeners
40 off your first two orders when you go
to freshly.com
slash theo that's right stop stressing
about dinner go to freshly
fresh l y
dot com slash theo for
dollars off your first two orders that's
freshly.com
theo for forty dollars off your first
two orders
you know if you're unhappy you can
adjust it
i've been unhappy a lot and and i try to
battle it
and um and sometimes it's a lifelong
battle
and sometimes it's it's just a momentary
battle you just need to get through the
moment
and i'm talking about better help
better help if you don't want to go to
the therapist in your town or
you don't have one near you but you need
help
you can start communicating asap it's
not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely
online betterhelp is committed
to helping you start living a happier
life today
a broad range of expertise is available
that's right help yourself start
achieving
your goals visit betterhelp.com
theo that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over one million people who
have taken in
charge of their mental health with the
help of an
experienced professional yep
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and this past weekend listeners get 10
off their first month oh thank you
better help
at betterhelp.com t-h-e-o
all right let's hit one more call here
and then we'll get to my little nephs
what up theo this
is molly from lost wisconsin um i want
to say
thank you for the existence of your
podcast and for the existence of you you
really
um inspire me to
talk to people it's not always been easy
for me to
have normal conversation i got a lot of
that social anxiety
um but i listen to your podcasts every
single day almost or
king of the sting or something like that
and it kind of
inspires me to just let the conversation
go where it might and it's so you don't
have to overthink anything
um but anyways
i have a question about traveling my
birthday is next month i
it's my golden birthday and i kind of
want to take a solo trip somewhere in
the states just for the weekend
i know you've traveled alone a lot and
so i'm wondering where you think
some of your favorite places to like
listen to music
uh meet some people go to bars maybe a
museum or park i don't know maybe get
some
non-local gold member
for my golden birthday i don't know um
okay she's trying to catch a little bit
of pain on the road i feel you baby girl
and thank you for the kind words
i want to say that first and foremost
and uh
you seem like a decent gal and um even
better than decent
and um and
yeah if you're trying to get it all
you're trying to get a food a drink
and maybe get curled up with somebody
you know maybe get squirreled out you
know with that hard freaking uh
squirrel that pants squirrel bro you
know that one that comes
taxidermied by the lord baby erection
um
you're in wisconsin
what is a fun
i feel like in the summer
minneapolis feels like a fun spot
if you're gonna go to like a city but
that's probably close to minneapolis
wisconsin
it shows capital i think or no is that
for uh
madison um
you don't want to go somewhere too hot
that's the thing unless there's water
there
you know south carolina is pretty dope
they have like folly beach they got some
really great beaches over there
i used to go out there a good bit you
can actually do some surfing
um but if school's not in
i don't know what some of the nightlife
is there is like
the food is really great it's hot as
hell though
denver what is denver like in the summer
[ __ ] i don't know lady
you know honestly like i don't know
but happy birthday to you and um
and yeah i feel you with the social
anxiety man this
i think us a lot of it is a byproduct
because we're less connected now
as humans so what used to feel kind of
normal
to our parents is awkward to us
you know i've been dating a gal a while
back and then she texted me and
ended things and that [ __ ] made me mad
man because but
that part of me didn't know she's 28 or
something i don't know and so i was like
well maybe she just
that's her they do that
but then you're just sitting around one
you know it's like
i don't know what i'm talking about
jesus christ all right thank you very
much molly
and you seem like a great lady and you
be swell out there and stay
safe too you know if you if you're a
brave woman you're going out there by
yourself what's a great city to go to
toronto is awesome if you haven't been
to toronto i think toronto
man i really love it you know i just
they're still screwing around up there
with the covet [ __ ] it's like what are
you doing
it's barely real figure this [ __ ] out
it's barely real figure it out
so let me see if there's anything else
we had a lot of great stuff i don't want
to
like just not talk about anything um
let me see hey theo this is adam from
salt lake again man
um also i i forgot to ask you um
adam thank you for calling man and salt
lake is real good man
if you like looking at white people dude
you
will love it well
i've been up in them dark arts you know
i was just wondering too i forgot to ask
you like
like i've been i've been trying to look
around
for for some aas and uh some ma
meetings like like what what do you look
for in
in going into an aaa where you can
really
kind of feel comfortable about what you
want to talk talk about and uh
thank you for the call man this is a
cool question
my experience with going into an aaa
meeting
or my suggestion i would offer to
anybody who asked about it would be
go to three meetings try out three
different ones
make sure that one of them is a speaker
meeting where somebody is speaking for
like an extended period of time
it could be 10 minutes or 15 minutes or
sometimes it's 30 minutes
40 minutes but you want to hear
somebody's story
uh and then try some other ones try one
that's a co-ed try one that's maybe just
men or women
if you're one of the other
and
uh and now and then and then make a
decision for yourself
just because they're different so you
want to get it they're not all the same
and i would just say listen for the
difference listen for the similarities
not the differences that's what they say
listen for the similarities and not the
differences
because it's easy for me a lot of times
to sit there and judge things
you know instead of be like what is
what am i okay with in here instead of
finding all the reasons already why i
can't stand something
because then i'm just not giving myself
a chance uh
but it's it's really interesting to go
to whether you feel like you have a
problem or not it's really interesting
to go to um
some type of 12-step meeting so best of
luck over there brother i'm sure there's
a lot of good ones in salt lake
um all right
hey theo my name's will and i'm from
charlotte north carolina
what's up big willy and i just graduated
uh gang baby that's a dub on the board
baby
big will getting out there in society
welcome to society well
go class 21 and i just wanna let you
know
that i use some of your words as a
uh just in your quote you know um
i remember i was listening to your
podcast one day and some some kid he was
like 21 or something called in
and he was like hey yeah if you had any
worse you younger stuff what would you
say
and i was sitting there listening to
podcasts and you like
you're talking about how you just go for
it and some of your exact words
try to use my finger quote here it is
you go said ask her out
no matter who she is whether she's a job
a new city
an actual person whether she's an
opportunity or fear
whatever she is man ask her out and
that's right
ladies and gentlemen just wanted to know
man and
uh honestly one of my dreams to be on
the podcast
and maybe one day i'll be there i just
want you know that
your words and even the crazy stuff
you've ever said and the
most deep stuff you've ever said it's
all it's all stuck with me
and i just wanna let you know that
you're very important
uh just role model my life thanks
thanks man that's real that's real real
sweet of you bro or not sweet of you i'm
saying bro no homo dog but you feel me
dog
you know that's nice you man i
appreciate that
yeah man i appreciate that you know we
all want to know we all want to have
those moments where we
know somebody lets us know that they
care you know
and those always hit me so hard because
i just didn't have a lot of that as a
child and people
you know i had a lot of trauma as a kid
and people say well sometimes you're
like well you talk about that a lot
or don't dwell on it i don't it dwells
on me
you know and so
i mean even if i look at the career
choice i made i needed like
i needed people to care about me but
even at a distance from a stage like i
needed
i had to keep this amount of control
over how i let
someone see me and care about me
um anyway kind of diatribe in there and
i don't want to get too
too out there before i get in with my
nephews coming in
and these little sugar tanks in here
uh but thank you man i appreciate that
man that means a lot dude
that means a lot that uh that you care
and i think if you're able to express to
people how you care about them man
and we've lost that along the way just
letting people know hey
you know you mean something to me we
you know like the woman on the on the
podium with the
athletic thing what if she just said
i'm so happy to be a part of this
country
it doesn't always represent everything
that i feel or say
but i'm happy to be in a place where
we can all feel and say freely
but maybe she did that by just saying
what she wanted to say i don't know
i don't know man i don't know exactly
what i'm thinking but thank you man i'm
excited uh
that you're graduating good luck out
there in the world and yeah ask her out
man
you know guys you know it's like you ca
you know who a guy's girlfriend or wife
is
it's the person they were brave enough
to ask out yeah whatever it is you go we
gotta ask her out
we gotta ask her out man
dude couple weeks ago girl on the beach
i freaking she was leaving to go to her
car i
strategically left at the same time okay
am i a
stalker i don't think i am okay
it was daytime um it was hot out
if i stalked i would do it in a colder
climate
or time time time it
you know night time um
but i i started talking to her
we had a mutual friend i got her ig i
messaged her
she didn't message me back okay
so first of all kate why don't you
eat one of my nuts
and secondly i did what i could
i showed up you know when i was
and for like 40 minutes i was sitting
far away from her on the sand and i was
trying to think of a reason to go over
there and then i saw a bird over there
and i was gonna try to go and look at
this bird and like
but then i'm like what [ __ ] guy he's
like hey
look at this bird hey what are you doing
here you know like i just couldn't think
of a line to come off of the bird
hey you know oh man there's birds out
here
what do you what do you know anything
about them
you know i just couldn't think of
anywhere to go with it so that's where
i'm at
my family said i don't want to spend a
ton of time on here but i do want to get
my nephews up here
i'll be right back uh with my nephews
zephy is one of them's name and the
other one is named
max all right sitting here right here
actually with my two nephews right here
a couple young buckaroos
and uh tell me about yourself let's
start with you brother
my name is max and i'm eight years old
and i'm taking an eight-hour road trip
from louisiana
okay and what brought you here to uh to
this area what brought you out here to
the central east brother
you looking for work or what no my
parents said that
um we were gonna go because it's a
summer
break and um we have nothing else to do
at home
okay and this fellow over here and how
do you know him this other guy
oh he's my brother okay are you guys
friends also would you say max or what
do you feel like
no okay we can be friends but we can be
mortal enemies as well
mostly mortal enemies though all right
and your name bud
my name is zephy i am nine years old
and um you looking for love
not not yet okay he stopped for like
three okay
that's fine man i've been there dude
i've definitely had times where i was
looking for
love and times where i wasn't did you
marry morgan wallin
i wouldn't marry i mean i don't think
both of us
prefer women yeah so but
i kind of get that i think if there were
if it were a different if we lived in a
different universe there could be a
chance i don't know
i don't know if he how are you i don't
know how he can communicate with each
other if you lived in a different
universe
i don't know it's a great question man
it is a great question
if we live in a different universe i
don't know i guess we would probably it
was a great question i think you would
probably
because you have to create a way to get
there
like a shuttle ship or something like a
space travel or you could just
dream of killing city war they went it
was either an infinity
war or in game they went in
the ship with the guardians of the
galaxy move this closer to you
and they broke suit and they broke
through the space and it created like a
yeah you have to break through space
yeah i'm look i'm not doing that
yeah i got enough going on here i mean
and there's like a space people could
do that because he's like albert
einstein i'm not doing what i'm saying i
just bought it
flowers i'm not doing second i'm doing
stuff at the house you bought a bunch of
flowers why does it say that truth
kind of fun twenty dollars because it
was a 120 dollar tree
what kind of flower you got like three
of them sean likes to spend that money
what kind of flowers i'm not sure so let
me ask you a question guys are you guys
single men or what's let's go one at a
time here let's start with you zephy are
you single these days or what's
what's uh love looking like in your life
have you started thinking about girls or
that kind of
or what what happens at nine years old i
like thinking about
food okay yeah me too but like
i'm not i'm not that much of a
of a person that will start a
conversation
i can sit and wait because i don't want
to be me
and to like and if somebody starts
talking to me
i just carry on and keep talking but
like
i usually don't like to engage in
conversations okay so you're more like
the you'll
you'll continue a conversation but you
won't start a conversation
yeah it's like if you're in a video game
you
land somewhere that is not contested but
you're not afraid to fight
right like that okay okay i got it
and max what about you were you the kind
of guy will start a conversation do you
even know
how to communicate what is going on with
you i really don't know how to talk to
girls at all
okay um and i like this one girl in my
class but i get bullied
you get bullied by her no i get bullied
by everyone because i like girl because
i like
a girl dang yeah did you let her know or
not
it's at school but like i think i think
i'm
done he he i think it's
what's everywhere what's every like
elementary school
crush you die you wait till
they they find out that they like you
that you like them
okay so how do you let someone know say
if there is a crush right
which is totally normal always boys you
just you you either ask your friend to
do it
or you write a note put it in your desk
and then leave school
yeah yeah that's my old move dude okay
so i have this really funny story
or leave town that's what i would do
leave town i have this really funny
story that started at like the beginning
in the school year and we're still we
were still laughing at it until the end
okay and this one
this kid my my best friend who was my
best friend his name is um
randall no ocean okay he liked this girl
named clarice
stop it and they liked each other and
then we were like
and then um so we're still laughing at
it for like the entire
school year and are they still together
i don't think
they didn't find each other but they're
probably what do you mean find each
other
i mean they have they they are they real
people guys
um to be real i have no idea okay it's
probably like a virtual assistant that
he uses of course that's what i was
gonna guess
now let's talk about some of you guys's
plans for the future i know you guys
right now
are you're nine years old you said zephy
and max i can start
you're six years old yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so
okay i can start yeah i just wanna know
some of your plans for the future
i want to be honest with you please i
want to be a foot doctor
oh really podiatrists they call it foot
man they call it
on the street wait a minute
what if the patient has foot fungus will
you eat it
look question will you eat the fun
[ __ ] guess or will you throw it away
do you know foot fungus tastes like goat
milk really i drink blood
every day for blue cheese tastes like
goat milk i know i'm a friend that's
addicted to blue cheese
in my in my um inoculations
in my cereal um yeah this is not true
most of my friends
this isn't true and my cereal instead of
using milk i use
goat milk with foot fungus in it i'm
addicted to caramel
really yeah i i take bottles he's
addicted to
caramel out of it okay so you want to be
a foot doctor
and zephy what do you when you think
about your future and where you are now
do you have any big plans do you have
any like what do you like what do you
kind of see yourself in the future a few
years down the road from now do you see
yourself kind of still living in the
same house do you see yourself having a
job
if it's a few years down
i'd probably
you gonna stay living with your parents
or are you gonna no want i'm gonna
move out when i have the money and stuff
okay and i want to move in to an
apartment
and get a job and a couple animals or
something or what
uh i want to get a
uh is it legal to have a bobcat as a pet
i bet it is oh um i want to get a bobcat
or like
i really want a a cockatoo or a parakeet
because you can talk to them
funny story actually my aunt
and my mother funny story actually
had a parrot a red parrot and he would
and he would say they would always say
like shut up ricky
and then and so and so um the parent
would always say
shut up ricky really and he would say
and the parent would say butthead
oh so the parrot is really he can he he
kind of has a
mind of his own huh yeah but it's like
an influence from his owners he's an
influencer
yeah i think so the parrot is yeah they
don't
the person's not on tick tock but no no
the parent went viral like a few years
later
oh dad he is friends he went viral on
he's friends with
um bryce hall he actually cut bryce
hall's hair
who did a parrot oh really oh good
i could imagine that now let me ask you
guys my dad is lebron james
no he's not max how do you know that
this
let's talk about some some things you
guys are not good at i want you to each
share something everything in my life
what are you good at like eating and
sleeping
okay and what are you not good at
everything
do you think you guys as parents will
stay together for a long time have you
guys talked about that or what does
their relationship seem like
uh yeah we joke around sometimes say
that they're cheating on each other
that's some reason
right max that's very
very you style but like at the same time
that's like a bad influence for your
children
i'm i don't have children but you're
like your children in the future
my child is um actually what are you
gonna name your children
i'm gonna name them uh
goobert i'm gonna name them goofy and
goober
oh wow are they gonna be twins or female
or male they're gonna be
attack helicopters oh wow beautiful
i could see that actually seems very on
brand with where we're headed as a
society
yes what do you think zephy now when you
start to look at um
the world today do you think the world's
headed in a good direction what are some
of your thoughts
um we need to stop the
old guys that wear rush
that wear shirts with russian flags on
them because i think they're american
communists
it's been said it's been rumored and i
think
stop pollution yeah sure but
yeah sure yeah sure global warming
global warming and
like like wow i'm just being serious and
we're probably just being
like crazy but look i'm trying global
warming is nice when you're at the beach
when it's nice and hot
let's be honest but but and
in our in our reality global warming
isn't good right i agree with you
except when you're at the beach except
that but like
so here's the question is do you think
enough people are willing to give up
going to the beach and having a nice
time no
in order for the world not to global
warm no
right yeah but like but most of the
people that go to the beach are like
adults and kids and most of the kids oh
what else would go a parrot
no an attack helicopter bro we we
brought our dogs driving the
who's driving the helicopter the attack
helicopter
the whole point of it being an attack
helicopter is because it drives
itself and crashes into everything and
blows stuff up but it's a more it's an
immortal helicopter
you guys are legends now i want to ask
you you're a legend
thank you and i want to ask you guys too
you guys are
you know what age do you feel like you
might want to settle down kind of i know
you guys
settle down you mean like let myself go
yeah
oh what does that mean getting older i
know right now you guys try to take care
of your diet take care of your body
37. i have a diet so 37 you're thinking
of
starting to just let it go huh yeah just
like james harden
21 yeah he went to the party
and then he came back fat i think he had
a lot of donuts
you might have do you guys have any
suggestions for me yes
okay you should tear those curtain downs
break the window
replace the windows with wall with walls
and paint
all the simpson simpsons characters on
the wall
because you had that in your studio in
l.a remember oh yeah
yeah would it be a bad idea we've
thought about doing something different
we're working with this church curtain
vibration i need something
i have no idea what it is so you said
you saw the first season of stranger
things right
yeah what was your favorite part my
favorite part
was i didn't watch uh i like that little
kid with the um
glasses on excuse me
i like the little kid with the glasses
on who
the glasses
what what
oh
i don't i don't remember are you okay
what did it look like
did you have curly hair i don't remember
oh um
did anyone even wear glasses in the
first season what are you guys okay
wait what are you doing what are you is
it was it barb
who's barb yeah let's go to the barb
yeah it wasn't barbed what are the
demogorgons do on friday night
they go to the barb wouldn't we like to
know
because they took her in the show my
favorite part everybody knows that
if anybody if anybody is watching this
that hasn't seen stranger things there's
spoilers my favorite part is when
is that when the point they're they're
is there like why is it on your face oh
yeah what that
when they're like take like when they're
on the bike chase with the big vans and
then
l flips over the van with her mind okay
okay okay okay okay
do you need a nap sir how do you guys
okay
we have a
[Music]
here do this max
are you thinking about getting plastic
surgery in the future
and like if i want to get plastic
surgery to look like my dog you should
get a nose job
yeah get a nose job i want to shave your
eyebrows and put eyebrow makeup on i
want to get my eyes sewn
closed and write party time on each one
i want to get my lip or my arm tattooed
saying
i'm a goofy goober
have you not seen spongebob no yeah
you don't you guys what did you do
as a kid if you didn't watch spongebob i
don't watch spongebob we rode our bike
cool we made ramps cool we hurt
ourselves
cool and the one you just said was the
fun part
people would vomit sometimes cool oh
pretty lit we used to eat ants
i got really sick like a week ago and i
grew up 12 times
and i stayed in a chair have you ever
had a feeling of being like
way down what's like poop poop
do you even believe yourselves
i mean i mean do you even believe in me
look guys i there's this guy that was
born with the voice of
the voice of morgan freeman he's
reincarnated as a lawn mower and the
only thing he can't do is open foil
paper
nice thanks do you want to hear my
morgan freeman impersonation
yes
what is wrong with you i didn't start it
yet here's my morgan freeman
impersonation all right
okay they said it would take a minute
600 years to get out of this here prison
but andy dufresne did it in less than
20.
why are you like why did i even
get get us on that topic what's
something you just want to tell the
people out there you know let's give
you guys about 30 seconds to just tell
people
what you want to say and then we can um
i want to say
that i am glad
to that i'm on this podcast because
i never thought i would be on a podcast
and that's all okay okay um what i want
to say is
i feel very glad to be on this podcast
and um just a thanks to my parents for
taking me out here
and stuff and um i actually want to
promote ceo's merch
by doing like a little sequence okay
okay
so i have his coding on
yeah whatever website he has go buy it
please okay all right man well bye
you know i love you guys and i'm glad
you guys were able to be here today
and um we just say at the end of the
episode
we say we'll probably go out with a
little bit of eddie nine volt again
uh to come up excuse me and it's the
same song that we came in with
what's that supposed to mean and i want
to thank everybody for being a part of
the show you can get tickets at
theovon.com
tour t-o-u-r
your what don't buy through any other
site because uh
it's a scam it's a scam website that's
how i watch icarly
there you go a lot of scams out there do
governments create
clouds for you to stop seeing the end of
the earth
now that's a question for this guy eddie
bravo a friend of mine who's not here
today
but i'm going to ask him you guys be
good to yourselves man
gang gang gang gang
[Music]
feels real good after i've been so blue
well i just broke up with my baby